foreign
is up next from Grand Junction hey
Courtney welcome to the show
hi thank you for having me absolutely
how can we help
well my question is relating to Family
Planning while on the baby steps and
seeing what the advice is for
wanting to grow your family but knowing
that might mean going in debt to
increase house size to accommodate so
we're talking about needing more space
to accommodate more children
yes okay so what's your living situation
right now
well right now
um my husband and I have two young boys
we live in a two bedroom one bath house
um we oh it's a it's a pretty humble
size house and we owe 146 000 on it
still okay what's it worth uh what's it
worth well right now where real estate
is at where we are at our home is valued
at around over 300 000 with all the
um fixing up that we've done to it over
the years cool what's your income like
um my husband makes just shy of 70 000.
cool and you're staying at home with the
kiddos
yes do you guys have any debt Courtney
we do we have one besides our home we
have a car loan that we are
um trying to crush out sweet what's that
what's the amount of that
about 13. all right so not much debt uh
to speak of do you guys have any money
saved anywhere we do
um we have more we have about 4 000
saved
um I'm not comfortable going down to
1000 saved to put it towards the car
loan just how expensive everything is
right now why
oh just because I don't know if anything
were to happen it doesn't seem like a
thousand dollars would last a family of
four very long in the true emergency and
actually my family is going through a
little thing right now because my
husband had a medical incident
um and he has been off of work for a few
months which has greatly reduced our
income okay and short-term disability is
about 50 of what his normal pay is so
it's showing me how quick you know
a thousand dollars really could go if we
you know got into a tighter situation
than what we are in well let's let me
take a moment let me let me take a
moment and debunk that for a moment
because I understand where you're coming
from
um but the thing that you've got to
realize is most people have no money
saved for emergencies like if in a
thousand dollar emergency came they
would have to put it on a credit card
because they don't have any cash saved
so the point that the fact that you have
money saved is a really great thing and
you know in your situation Courtney it's
actually it's wonderful because if you
were to
keep a thousand dollars saved for baby
step one you could pay off that 13k car
note in no time now in the in the
instance where you know you have a job
loss or something like that you know
you're able to pause the baby steps and
get back on your feet but you know I do
want you to see this as a plan that can
work for you you know I know that your
husband is going through something right
now but I don't once once the Smoke
Clears on that I don't want that to keep
you from working the baby steps and
getting to where you want to be because
I agree with you I think that as a
family of four you want as much
stability as possible and I truly
believe that working through this plan
is going to get you on the most stable
footing because baby step two is going
to get you completely out of debt and
then you're going to save up three to
six months of expenses in your case six
months of expenses because it sounds
like your husband is the only one
working
and that means after that you're able to
save up for a home and you're going into
that new home purchase whether it's
selling the one you have and upgrading
you're going into that with completely
firm footing and a firm foundation does
that make sense
it does I I do hear that
yeah and I think Courtney for you the
question you know that you you asked for
growing a family
um you know I never want money to be the
thing or stuff to be the thing that
stops you from growing your family so I
would say grow your family and I know
this sounds great people probably hate
me for this but I'm like
I've I swear our kids lived in a pack
and play in a closet they don't care for
her for a good bit too so I know that
like yeah it's it's a it's a small home
um but I would not be under the
impression I understand it would be nice
to have more room for sure absolutely
and maybe you guys are at a point that
you're like you know what another baby
would stress us out so let's just wait
another two years get some get some
things under us and as a family that's
how we decide but we never tell people
not to get married or not to expand
their family because of their their
money situation I think that that is a
very personal uh decision that you guys
can make and if you want to and you are
at a point like I really want another
baby then do a quarter you guys are
gonna figure it out and you may have a
few years where it's where it's tight
you're like oh my gosh we got to pay off
that car and we're gonna save up for the
emergency fund it's gonna give you that
much more motivation you know to then
figure out the housing and say okay good
you know the house is maybe even worth a
little bit more
um and we're able to have a good down
payment you know and you and you keep it
going so this isn't a plan that's going
to take you 10 years right it's a plan
that's going to take you maybe 36 months
absolutely and so I would say Courtney
if you guys want to keep expanding a
family I would do it
um but that doesn't mean you have to you
know go take on a bigger house because
you guys just aren't I wouldn't say in a
great position to do that right this
moment I would like Jade said pay off
the debts have that good emergency fund
in place
um and then go from there and and I
think that's just going to give you a
lot less stress
yeah I think that we could be done with
baby step three by the end of this year
or early into the next year and so at
that point
foreign
what do you say about increasing
your mortgage
so the the principle like yeah totally I
hear you yeah so the principle would
remain the same you know we teach that
we don't want
um your mortgage payment to be any more
than 25 of your take-home income and
that's all things considered the
insurance the taxes All Things
Considered no more than 25 of your
take-home pain of course we want you to
get a 15-year fixed rate mortgage how
does that sound
yes I understand that yep I think that
yes
very good and I can't stress enough
Courtney because I don't think that I I
feel like you might be trying to go past
it maybe I misread that but I cannot
stress enough please please please work
these steps in order they they work I
could tell that you're like now let me
just see what if I went ahead and did it
like this I beg of you not to do this
thing I'm telling you work the steps in
order I my husband and I we try to be
too much of a of a rebel but it seems
like if I can foresee crushing the car
loan and the next you know within the
year you know less than the year oh yeah
then
um it's
it's hard like I said it's hard for me
to want to let go of a little bit of
extra savings that we have
um like I just kind of like to like set
it like just forget about it back there
just because you know if you had to put
your family up in a hotel for a week you
know like that would be more than a
thousand dollars you know and then and
not having to go in debt to do it but I
I
I'm new to hearing about the baby steps
plan and we've been listening to
um the audiobook and I'm like really
compelled and I'm really inspired and I
you know want to trust in it and trust
it Courtney trust it trust it millions
of people use this plan to get out of
debt to save up money to buy homes to
become baby steps millionaires the plan
I tell people the plan works if you work
it if you kind of do ish like Dave says
all the time ish is a wish and you'll be
wishing that you had worked the plan the
way the plan says so that's all I'm
saying I'm saying work the plan in order
you can do what you want to do but I
think that you should work the plan in
order baby step one two three three B
that's what I would do absolutely Jade
well said well said but but you know and
you know to Courtney I'm like I I
totally get what you're thinking right
if you've been in the Viewpoint of money
of the world yeah then it's like well of
course you know we'll we'll get a bigger
house and have a baby expand and keep
some money yeah all of it right like I
understand where you're coming from
Courtney but part of this change is
feeling the change and the change is
going to be uncomfortable any change is
uncomfortable it's not easy uh but just
I would say trust the process and you
know what Courtney if you get you know
18 months into this and you hate it
you can there you go it's a free world
you can say I'm I'm going broke I'm not
doing this anymore uh but we really do
believe it leads to freedom and
stability so good luck Courtney thanks
for calling so Jade our last caller
um we talked through you know some
things about her wanting to expand her
family and her home and all of that but
she did mention that her husband's
income was cut in half because of a
disability and there was kind of this up
in the air situation so uh I I think
that what she had said was that they
were coming out of that so that's why we
were a little bit gung-ho on it but
that's true but for those of you
listening just now there is a there is a
storm mode quote unquote uh time in life
right so that could be if you are
um you know expecting a baby if there's
a medical emergency if there's a big
move coming up that you know we do say
you can pause the baby steps and pile up
some cash to get through those
quote-unquote storms and then when those
past things settle you just jump right
back in yeah
um and so for her you know if that if
that medical situation was going to
continue then she should keep the four
thousand dollars sitting there that's
right that's right but it sounded like
she was coming out of it that's why Jade
and I were just honored yeah I really
wanted to make sure that she wasn't
going to go into home buying MO do all
this stuff without working the baby
steps for sure for sure so I wanted to
clarify that but but it's great because
again that's a question yeah and a
situation that a lot of people are in
and because of the housing market and
people's emotions around that it can be
this like wishy-washy feeling of oh my
gosh our house is you know yeah that's
gone up in value and not all of it so